[Musique]
non non le madison où l'amour ne dure
pas toute la nuit il ne faut jamais que
tu non non non on allie panneaux et
surtout jamais notre souci de tous les
cons dire à ta carte y avait un ton
appel tu ne connais pas tu allais nous
sais-tu que c'est ta jeunesse la plus
grande des richesses
chaque matin les yeux encore de sommeil
ou pousser la porte vitrée de votre
bistrot familier le café de la gare le
bar du chien qui fume chez lancel ou
encore la cigale sportive
à moins que ce ne soit au p'tit quinquin
et c'est bon cinq minutes de pause de
banzai vous serez m'en excuse et d'une
banquette
pendant que fusaient percolateur un
petit crème un petit blanc un petit marc
les bistrots c'est aussi et tournai
l'apéro sur le coup de midi ou après le
boulot et peut-être êtes-vous de celles
qui attendent tamari où le fils aîné
la table est mise pour quoi ne rend-il
pas le repas sera froid la paix et
bréchet
votre bistrot cody n'autre bistrot venez
avec nous en faire la tournée elle a
commencé à paris belleville ménilmontant
et champs elysées sans oublier
montparnasse on s'y trouve bien
mais ne croyait pas que c'est un repère
d'alcooliques sincèrement le français de
la boire son petit coup de vin rouge son
petit vin blanc
mais je ne vois pas pour faire supprimer
dans un pays productif sauf chez nous en
france
j'enverrai sur j'aime bien clients
qu'ils dégustent je viens puis un 4 e
silva n'ont pas lebron qui vient bois
pour faire pour se saouler me remettre
et sport
juste pour accorder avec une table louis
xiii en glace oui ça dépend des
dimensions monsieur 60 je vois réserve
mais pas bien et discuter au bistrot abc
fait plutôt froid
oui on peut prendre un pot avec les
maillages quelques photos que je vous
présenterai
[Musique]
jeunes et anciens bistrots dans ce
week-end au processus y compris de
rencontres m'ont fait subir crises le
plus sélectionné choisir mr en
particulier c'est notre but sera
vraiment cahier vous êtes une figure de
ce marché bien au coeur des puces et
pourtant des filiales et a beaucoup
est ce qui vous arrive d'avoir des états
d'âme mais est-ce que lorsque j'avais
ses états d'âme ou réfugiées au bistrot
du coin comme tout le monde
j'ai des états d'âme qui dépend de
l'atmosphère qui dépendent de
l'environnement de mes affaires
personnelles de mes amours de mes
affaires et je dois reconnaître que
d'aller au bistrot c'est un des moyens
d'y échapper un peu aux puces ou
travaillé trois jours par semaine et
vous pensiez quand même temps au bistrot
le moins possible on est des brocanteurs
on est dans nos stands alors il ya une
fuite de l'instant d'énervement qu'on
peut avoir au bout de cinq ou six heures
de dix ans de parlotte de discussion et
comme depuis quelques années on a
découvert l'alcoolisme mondain nous on a
peut-être découvert dans notre petite
sphère et si l'alcoolisme ce bistrot
c'est à dire que
on va prendre un petit whisky ou de houe
quelquefois deux et demi pour se changer
les idées mon dieu ça fait pas de mal
bien que ce soit pour mon vin parce que
lui aussi une autre façon de le faire
c'est soit au milieu d'un décor qu'on
s'est créées mais ça c'est beaucoup plus
dangereux
un délice et au bistrot en vente tout le
monde et disons le mot des copains sont
des copains
[Musique]
j'aime encore fournir les batteries
je mets
un petit côté un petit chalet en cause
ont congédié l univers inconnu ce n'est
pas important
c'était le plus costaud déjà main
en vrai tu pas payant
[Rires]
ensemble on fit ou chaloupés et le soir
sans volumes en jeu tous deux
souhaitaient tant qu'art et pour
l'éternel roman
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour passer le temps l'a pas certain
c'était souvent des gens font qu on est
ici pour se retrouver qu'avec face au
vent qu'ils pensent vivait seul par
exemple les veufs les célibataires
11h30 c'est leur élégante au fouquet's
mois s'écoulent et religieux tous les
jours toutes les heures sont testées
qu'en principe il faut être une habitude
comme un damné pour opérer mais au
contraire la familiarité des premiers
maires d'être les premiers verdon il
faut que je m'adapte de temps à 8 ans
est retenu douaniers avec georges
derrière les prétoires des fillettes
deuxième un peu de l'ostracisme avant
une pancarte curieuse les années ce ne
sont pas deux au bar procès sans que
j'existais que parfois c'est très très
bien assimilé au sable pourrait pourtant
peut-être est-ce que vous assistez au
démarrage de grandes affaires de
nouveaux scénarios pour juin de nouveaux
epr effet comment
et l'institution de nouveaux cabinets
dans la politique ça c'est notre
problème alors là vous ces questions de
politique je me suis pas trop évident et
qui traîne elle est fermée pour les
journalistes
voilà ça fait partie du dispositif
[Applaudissements]
jacques des chemins directeur des fous
4,6 main ce sont des gens qui sont
comblés la fortune
en secondaire qu'elle rejoint obligé de
réellement à mon avis de s'échapper de
leur bureau ils sont le moteur des
employés et la de la relève d'autre
chose que de leurs affaires que vous
avez ici elle entendra parler de leur
rappeler qu'on appelle les bars
américains
je dois passer par là ils paraissent
mythique l'homme qui se retrouvent pour
tous les jours se reforme tous les
journaux mais le son les clients se
tournent eux c'est tous les jours il
commet un peu l'ambiance est crevé
apporte une certaine heure caoutchouc qu
est ce qui vous arrive d'entrer dans un
petit bar sans prétention écoutez
monsieur pour être franc je suis comme
tout le monde on arrive à faire un écart
ces hausses bistrot préféré me sur mes
invités dans le cadre de ce we à
proximité et gémeaux l'atelier également
souffert de la chaussure sur disons
fabricant vous êtes un enfant de lui
quelque cinquante ans il est temps que
vous habitez que ça va attend quartier
c'est une rencontre avec des confrères
levis 36 et c'est une course ensemble on
se concerte on discute de nos affaires
de nos santés évidemment ce qui se passe
en général
voyons des pauvres types vivez nos
bistrots chercher un peu de consolation
à peu de chaleur humaine
un auditoire aussi oui et les gens
aiment bien parler une seconde et se
produit une chose c'est que un type à
cinq minutes de retard
ils hésitent à rentrer chez lui parce
que la soupe à la grimace l'attend alors
que souley une femme qui lui fait la
gueule des sports et bien me till fui
cette atmosphère là et où va-t-il bien
enregistrons l'es6 en mieux que chez lui
et les femmes seules du vélo be thrown
away sont des clientes
oui oui les deux clientes régulières
aussi qu'ils s'ennuient un petit peu
chez eux qui viennent te retrouver des
amis je vous expliquez moi tous les
soirs je viens ici centre caf et madame
marcelle avec une dame donner à manger
aux chats la jeune et les baies en bas
si je les aime
inutile de vous dire qu'on venir leur
donner à manger est pas évident alors si
matin
qui alors on est content de venir chez
marcel qu'on s'est un petit peu qui
comprend le dit tellement oui moi je
reste un bon petit moment
voyez je vais bien tout petit chien oui
mais on m'a fait cadeau de perruches oui
mais je vous assure c'est bon ça va bien
sauf à n'importe quelle maison sir louis
et essen sociale et les retombées la
mission qu on jamais vu un joueur du
monde et il y avait de la valeur on sait
qu'on était des gosses de la rue
olalalala oui 50 50 de lui
clément lépi dix et cinquante cinq
années de bistrot dans le coin presque
oui j'ai passé ma
jeunesse au café avec les copains vous
donner une définition personnelle peut
être du bistrot qu'est ce qu'un bistrot
convoi le bistrot c'est le lieu
d'animation naturel du quartier on
cherche actuellement à faire de
l'animation dans les quartiers avec des
maisons de la culture avec des
expositions de peinture ou avec des
ciné-clubs l'animation c'est le café
c'est le bistrot et le bistrot d'à lui
est il différent des autres bistrots de
paris les bistrots de la ville était
différent d'abord parce que nous
retrouvions en famille
j'étais toujours les mêmes camarades et
même pas tant à nous retrouver soi
devant le comptoir au soir devant devant
les tables où nous jouions aux cartes et
même devant les billards et belleville à
une place privilégiée dans paris pour
les bistrots
faut quand même dans votre clientèle
d'habitués 5 6 ans excellent à passive
et vous après chacun pour rassembler
tous ces gens ils sont cinq heures mais
comme un modèle ancien clientèle
directes depuis 18 ans mais qu'elle
était une question d'habitude viennent
ici ont toujours les mêmes qui est des
retraités
des jeux nautiques lille a dit m je suis
à 100 avec un des deux jeunes à capuche
et artisans de leur besoin de conclure 6
ans il est né ici pour faire leur
proposition de rejoindre l'otan parce
que tant les retraités bien apathique
fait plus tôt
y avoir des beaux bijoux van rij la
mission avec le centre et jean du tcc
que des sujets de conversation
bien souvent le jeu la maladie sont
souvent malades étant avec son lieu
entre les genres pieds dans l'eau on
attendait la zmp médecin n'avait semblé
clermont mais en fait je les connais
tous fait longtemps que la praline est
un personnage de très particulier du
quartier qui se promènent à droite et à
gauche il va sauter sa fille goualante
demande pouvoir de ciment à la marquise
chez weber et c'est un homme un garçon
que nous aimons beaucoup d'ailleurs fait
partie de notre folklore un te diront de
rester sage
mais si tu savais petit come to n'habite
vie quand c'est pour ça je le répète la
jeunesse n'a qu'un temps le temps jamais
ne l'arrête c'est ce qui est embêtant et
les bistrots diffic enfants comme celui
ci simmons le beurre peu après vos
disques auraient remplacé d'ailleurs qui
est terrible c'est que les bistrots
traditionnels sont démolis non seulement
démoli mais pour les modernisant les
transformant en pub anglais alors ce ne
sont plus des bistrots parisiens sont
d'époque dans son époque avec des
lumières au dessus du comptoir ça a été
terrible pour moi c'est un kobe strauss
un correspondant à l'idée que j'en ai
pour moi ce bistrot c'est un endroit où
on va je voulais dit tout à l'heure
retrouver des amis et de leurs biens un
moment de détente
on se sent joie
[Rires]
on parle de tableau entre parenthèses du
trio et huit civières 40 56 et pour deux
verres de vin il aurait donné un tableau
volontiers malheureusement vous ne
connaissez pas tellement ce genre de
choses on n'a pas accepté mais la rumeur
voulait rouvrir et aux deux bouts je
vais prendre un rouge et or à jugulaire
un peu plus mondain qui peuvent marcher
à des alcootests ekeng pour se défendre
a ajouté la personne ne voit pas de
l'alcool dans une
et comme tel par exemple ne sont pas son
coup a pas de jus de fruits vraiment un
contact avec une qualité essentielle le
contact avec la clientèle ou bien ces
impacts humains
[Musique]
est-ce que les deux sol est un bistrot
historique des à lire je pense que ça a
été à l'époque des halles un lieu de
rencontres très important peut-être
parce que géographiquement il se trouve
au coin de la rue rambuteau de la rue
saint denis peut être également parce
qu'il ya une atmosphère autant que je
puisse avoir les céramiques date
d'environ 70 ans
je pense qu'il est resté sous sa forme
ancienne
nous avons des clients ici des habitués
qui viennent soit parce que le cadre
leur convient soit parce que
l'atmosphère leur convient eh bien ces
gens là on a les échanges extrêmement
intéressant parce ne pas croire que la
clientèle de ce genre de bistrot est une
clientèle très bas c'est faux et des
gens très bien qui viennent mais qu'ils
viennent voir ici
hip hop
aulas monsieur en tenant compte de 2,969
méjean bouteille par la maison
un petit beau jeu les patrons je vous
proposerai aussi mon niveau de jeu
vevo cave personnelle du personnel
on vous livre de porc tous directement
nos propriétés quand même la propriété
vous avez le fus qui vient d'arriver
cette valeur c'est un flux de 1973 qui
va être mis en bouteille en dernier
chargé de l'une à l'autre à la nôtre
bien ça lui manquait quand j'ai eu de
grands tous creuser à côté à la place
des halles qui souffre d'un gros qu'on a
eue au coeur c'est quand ils sont partis
le donneur le morceau sable c'est un
bide complet m'bia est plus personne
mais alors vraiment sonné creux dans la
campagne
est-ce que nouvelle clientèle qui se
forment maintenant vingt maisons une
répression faire ici c'est un peu
spécial parce que nous avons une
clientèle de dégustateurs et clients qui
réussissent et pour déguster pour voir
du bon vin et acquérir les lieux porto
nous avons aussi de vieux canal hausse
d'hier moderne elle puis nous faisons
sur le carré blanc qui a fait fléchir la
maison intérêts blancs qui est sûr c'est
que l'on a d'un seul café blanc c'était
un secret s'est ainsi retrouvée nous
mêmes il ya beaucoup de plans qui
rentrent composition et nous siégeons
belle robe blanc à 54,2 grec nous
arrosons ensuite reçu et nous et aux
clients connaissent aussi le café blanc
aurait beaucoup de clients que nous
ciblons n'avançait pas plus loin parce
que le vent il craint la lumière avec
votre caméra je ne souhaite pas d'accord
seulement pourrait prendre des photos
monsieur monsieur doit nous offre ici
encore que faysal qu'une lampe
électrique
voyez-vous monsieur ici dans cette
vieille cave je vous fais avoir quelque
chose de cassé son bel air ici dans les
cales c'était les anciens aussi hier
j'ai trouvé ça dans le fond de ma
troisième club est allé bouteille aussi
rugueux rippert tous les ans mais les
vétérans bouteille c'est très bon pour
les maux de ventre le coni qui pâtit
c'est ça la france bien que oui c'est un
petit gars se remplace un thé la pilule
pour les femmes qui est un produit
naturel
c'est un produit j'annulerai la vipère
et ce produit naturel l alcool ou si
vous avez là oui j'en ai sous les
de loire voilà la bouteille concerne le
club et la bouteille que j'ai mis en
bouteille l'année dernière au mois de
mai parce qu'enfin si pour les semences
et répondant à contacter et rentrer le
cohérente
on les voit dans l'élite avec les
poussions couple épisode manière que la
vipère respire et allégerait trois jours
et au bout de trois jours on arrive le
bouchon on verse le mar ont la bouche
avec un mouchoir et heureusement que
plein et à ce moment là entre le liquide
le replay le bouchon à blair et david
prs décent et leur montre va chercher
l'air alors ça dépend la résistance de
la bête qu'elle met une heure une heure
et demie avant de crever et quand elle
est pour crever et le rejette plus
qu'elle absorbait qu'elle restera
bouteilles grâce morale envers la
bouteille un homme à ce ratio à l'ancien
libéro efron se sait toujours se dire
l'ensemble des beurs et au fromage
pourrait nourrir ou pas du tout mais
ouais il ya 60 70 ans et à plus de 130
la mesure existe et à cette époque là
n'est ce pas comme nous sommes dans une
bâtisse où il y avait des arcades et que
les arcades sont séparés à cette époque
là avec des cloisons et c'était un match
différent différer les chevaux de
s'occuper et la réparation des galas
bras et en même temps que le café et par
la suite tous à cet évent du lézard
tablette est séparée et les beurs et
formage sont implantées mais bref à
toujours rester l'enseigne alors
beaucoup croyaient que j'étais le beh
web beurre et fromage mais le vrai assez
qui est beau ouvriers français
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui passent leur vie d'un
côté du comptoir vous même page est vous
l'avez passer de l'autre côté c'est à
dire que vous avez regardé les gens qui
étaient d'autres cela pendant combien
d'années pendant 40 ans toujours au même
endroit alors pourquoi on vous retrouve
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va te changer de
cadre puis c'est pas un peu de grand
trou qu'on a croisé à la place de celui
qui fait votre ambition et j'ai quitté
l'ancien mr j'ai casé vient me suis
effacé une partie de ma vie là-bas petit
job d'être autographes et votre
attention que ce succès sur n'importe
quel événement et vous avez choisi la
mort d'un bistrot pourquoi cette
inspiration bien j'ai choisi de faire
ses photos sur ce bistrot sur ce bistrot
parce que j'habite juste en face et j'y
allais souvent avec des amis où ils
avaient donc ou sortes d'affections pour
cet endroit au moment où j'ai su qu'il
allait disparaître j'ai voulu témoigner
de la dernière journée de vie de cet
endroit c'est justement ce qui me
plaisait que c'était une atmosphère très
chaude et abbas était une date qui était
plutôt embarrassé
et bien maintenant on va voir une
avancée tourner quand même dépasser
l'autre jour vous y trouverez pas plu à
fait c'est triste fête triste et du
quartier triste mais ça sert de garage
pour les motards dans la marre oui mais
ils ont arraché la droite va devoir être
démolis ions var une otan la démolition
parce que je crois qu offrir ça m'a
dégoûté un tout petit peu quand même que
ceux qui sont contre la négation de
formica qui vidéo et c'est l'un de
l'autre c'est quoi c'est tout pas
tiens
dans belleti votre vis trop à la ville
de rouyn était sur l'un des plus beaux
emplacements de paris même du monde et
maintenant il ya un grand trou à la
place et au fait mal au coeur un oui oui
oui ça le fait moralement mal au coeur
et ça fait surtout mal au coeur au porte
monnaie
mais pourquoi pourquoi parce que je n'ai
plus de clients
pratiquement depuis six ans les halles
sont partis j'ai bien travaillé du temps
l'idéal est maintenant à chacun une
lettre école vous ouvriez à quelle heure
le matin 1h30 du matin
il démarrait à quoi le matin donc fait
elle que ferro moins que free cah
néerlandais avait quatre lots rôle jouez
votre chantage est-ce que vous avez
commune est que fait dans le boys une
vingtaine de milles ce serait parait
beaucoup prenant je ne pourrais pas
qu'il nouvelle clientèle va arriver
parce qu'on est en train de rénover le
quartier
je transporte tout une bille en jet
bharti kher au dessus du métro mais je
loue après la brillante et revenir sur
le ce même courrier que vous nous
annonciez j'extrais aussi ces quelques
lignes
n'imaginez pas une téléspectatrice jaune
et vermillon ce n'est à cause du froid
actuelle mais j'ai envie de vous parler
un petit peu de l'importance du bistrot
du coin
il est dans des pays aux bigots ce que
l'église est aux femmes
c'est en effet le dimanche matin qu'il
connaît les records d'affluence
même les jour d'enterrement c'est au
bistrot que les au matin où la fin de la
messe de là il se rend au cimetière et
c'est toujours là que tout se retrouve
non pour noyer leur chagrin dans
l'alcool mais parce que le bistrot c'est
le foyer du village aussi chauffer
l'hiver et en s'y rafraîchir l'été
j'ai connu mon village de 500 habitants
sans café une lente agonie mon village
était mort et des joueurs de belote
désemparés en fait dans un village il ya
trois maisons la mairie école et le
bistrot
il fallait bien aller
un jour on peut voir un jeu quotidien du
mois
progrès
- meilleur
je demande une fillette au bar on
n'avait pas plu émergent
non non ce n'est pas une petite
bouteille d'ailleurs ou des formules ans
et sur table grand danger négation et
schering plough 21
[Rires]
nous avons chanté
[Musique]
les trois lauréats dans la nuit sans
lune
blair
[Musique]